the Sun is also a star hit the big
screen on May 17th 2019 the novel turns
movie is a massive success and it has
fans all over the globe praising actors
Charles Melton and Yara Shahidi
for their stellar performances we've got
some funny and cute behind-the-scenes
moments lined up for you watch until the
end to find out what Charles's go-to
dance move is oh I'm waiting for
something but not for an apology
actors Charles Melton and Yara Shahidi
play the roles of Daniel BAE and Natasha
Kingsley respectively their performance
was downright amazing but that comes as
no surprise after all they're both
seasoned actors with a string of hidden
talents you probably recognize Charles
from the hit TV series River del Charles
plays the role of Reggie mantle and has
also appeared on TV series like Glee and
American Horror Story Charles was born
in Janu Alaska and is half Korean half
American
he loves to embrace his culture and
always has a good time doing so although
some fans might be watching Yara perform
on the big screen for the first time
she's actually been acting since she was
7 years old however she is known for
playing the role of Zoe Johnson on the
hit TV series lavish and grown as' Yara
is half african-american and half
Iranian and she's an absolute beauty so
it comes as no surprise that Yara was
director Rui Ruis though Young's first
choice when it came to playing Natasha
Bry posted this behind the scenes
picture of her and Yara hanging out on a
park bench it's clear that Riya ara and
Charles all get along really well which
made filming the movies so much more fun
and Rui was there to help out her stars
every step of the way
acting in a popular movie like the Sun
is also a star is super exciting it's
been pretty incredible which is why
actors usually can't wait for premiere
night Charles and Yara looked absolutely
stunning during the premiere and their
moods were at an all-time high
thanks to their many fans and loyal
supporters Charles and Yara posed with
cameras Johnson and Jake Cho on the red
carpet their fellow actors play the
roles of Omar and Charlie respectively
in fact many of Charles and yds close
friends and family members came to
support the actors nearly the entire
riverdale crew kay
to celebrate their friend success now
that's love the cast of the Sun is also
a star recently toured around the United
States to promote their movie and meet
their fans here's a pic of Charles Jake
and author Nicola hanging out in a loft
in San Francisco it's clear that the
press tour has led to the actors forming
some unbreakable bonds the Cruz press
tour came to an end in Miami where
Charles and Yara got to meet hundreds of
their dedicated fans the crew was
overwhelmed by the amount of love and
support they were showered with wherever
they went but that only made them more
excited about their films grand debut
it's no secret that Charles and Yara
became fast friends while on the set of
their movie after all they did spend an
entire summer getting to know each other
from book tours to heartfelt interviews
there's nothing that's on-screen couple
didn't do if there's one thing they did
over and over again it's photoshoots
have you ever wondered how these two
actors manage to look flawless in every
single shoot well their shooting process
goes something like this
Yara was totally mocking Charles's go-to
pose way to go Charles work those angles
filming a movie can be stressful at
times but when your cast is this awesome
as this one there's always room for fun
Charles's girlfriend and a Riverdale
co-star camilla mendes came to visit the
set of the Sun is also a star last
summer and totally made herself at home
if you think Charles and Camilla are
couple goals leave a red emoji in the
comment section but if you think Charles
and Yara are the real OTP leave a blue
heart in the comments instead Charles
and Yara have been spending a lot of
time together which is why they're super
comfortable by each other's side during
an interview with Teen Vogue the
co-stars were asked to play a game of
truth or dare and things got um
interesting to say the least
being the rebel that he is Charles chose
to dare for his first round luckily for
him he wasn't asked to do anything too
crazy but he did have to tell Yara a
joke what did one wave say to the other
wave nothing they just waved we love
this simple joke and the fact that it's
Charles's favorite one makes it even
more special
Charles's next dare was a little more
embarrassing but he didn't seem fazed by
it whatsoever
he was dared to teach Yara a new day
smooth and she knocked it out of the
park well turns out that yar was already
familiar with the book dance
have you ever busted this move out
before or did Charles and Yara just
teach you something new when it comes to
dancing Charles and yar are on a
wavelength of their own as a matter of
fact they even busted a move or two
while shooting for the cover of
Cosmopolitan magazine it's nice to know
that these on-screen lovers have amazing
chemistry on and off the set we'd love
to see how friendly these two are behind
the camera dancing isn't the only thing
Charles and Yara are good at because
well they're both pretty good singers
too during the same Teen Vogue interview
both Yara and Charles same happy
birthday to each other in different
languages Yara is half Persian and
speaks perfect Farsi whereas Charles is
half Korean and knows a few phrases in
his mother tongue
wow these two are simply adorable we
love how multi-talented they are we
previously mentioned that director Rui
Ruis so young and knew that she wanted
yard to play Natasha from the get-go
however she wasn't exactly sure who she
would cast as Daniel but after meeting
Charles and watching his audition reel
Rai slowly began piecing the puzzle
together but before she could cast
Charles as Daniel Charles and Yara
needed to do a chemistry read the actors
came clean about the first time they met
on the set of virgin radio Toronto want
the most serious in the movie and the
latest single movies we're super happy
that ride picked Charles to be Yara's
co-star they look so good together and
have some amazing on-screen chemistry
did you guys know that the Sun is also a
star is loosely based off of author
nikola Yoon's life well the author chose
to use her very own love story as an
inspiration for the movie Nicola and her
husband David are an adorable couple and
their love is being celebrated all
around the globe do you guys think that
Charles and Yara did them justice we
think they totally nailed their roles
so which behind-the-scenes moment what's
your favorite let us know in the comment
section below give this video a big
thumbs up if you enjoyed watching the
Sun is also a star and be sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]